hi and welcome to the video series of
piyo techniques explained in five
minutes where I explain our concept
about biological technique in less than
five minutes and if you haven't yet
subscribed to my channel so please
subscribe today's installment we'll be
talking about in situ hybridization so
as you know in situ hybridization is one
of the important methods by which mRNA
can be probed and we can ask two
questions using this kind of technique
whether a specific mRNA is present or
not and if the mRNA is present then
where it is present basically its
localization so in this particular
example we probed a particular mRNA
which is present in subcellular
localization in the hippocampus so let's
just understand it in a better manner so
here is a mouse brain coronal section
where you can see the hippocampus is
labeled by this particular molecular
marker or the gene which is expressed in
the dentate gyrus location of the
hippocampus so if the gene is expressed
in the specifically in the dentate gyrus
of hippocampus then its mrna would be
localized in that region in that
cellular region right so you here you
can see a lot of mRNA of that particular
gene is present in the dentate gyrus now
you need a way of probing that mRNA in
order to understand where it is present
and how much it is present so here is
the mRNA of interest that you want to
probe in order to understand the mRNA
whether it is present or not you need a
probe the probe is basically a
complimentary DNA sequence now our
complementary sequence for that against
that RNA right now the probe is labeled
with some specific type of label which
we would be discussing later but it can
be detected by an enzyme lean linked
antibody system or a fluorescently
linked antibody system now let's just
move over the technique one by one so
here you can see there are some mouse
brain sections the earliest step is to
treatment with Proteus to get rid of all
the proteins because we don't need
proteins because we are detecting here
the mRNA then it
is left for overnight probe
hybridization which is the most
important state where you put specific
probes to a probe for one particular
mRNA or a particular type of mRNA and
after the probe hybridization we expect
that the room has bind to the mRNA and
it would present it would be present
only in the place where the mRNA is
present and it would show the endogenous
location of the mRNA after that there
would be stringent washes several washes
to get rid of the excess probes then we
can as these probes are labeled by each
oxygen in in this particular case it can
it can be probed using specific enzyme
linked antibody now the enzyme link and
antibody binds to the probe the
detection level on the probe and then we
can put substrate which would ultimately
develop into a color reaction and this
color reaction would ultimately tell in
the section or in the look in location
of the whole brain where this particular
mRNA is present now the color reaction
is based on an enzyme substrate reaction
the enzyme which is linked to the
antibody is known as alkaline
phosphatase so the alkaline phosphatase
has its substrate which is n V T and B C
IP so alkaline phosphatase which it
would convert B C IP into a in Doxil
intermediate which would further react
with in n bt to form our in soluble dye
of formazan like a salt which would be
in blue or purplish in color and that
color would tell us where the specific
expression pattern is and we would
understand whether the mRNAs present in
that location or not if present how much
it is present now other ways of
detecting that is fluorescently labeled
antibodies where it could be detected by
the normal method of fluorescence and
this kind of modification of the in situ
hybridization is known as fluorescence
in situ hybridization or fish though
this technique is variant
and importance and developmental
biologist or cell biologists frequently
use these techniques this technique has
a drawback so it can tell you roughly
that how much mRNA is present or not but
it cannot quantitatively tell you how
much how many copies it is present or
not in order to understand that
quantitative estimate quantitative
real-time PCR is the option but still in
order to understand the cellular
localization of the mRNA or
understanding anatomical look at
localization of that particular mRNA
this is one of the best technique
available so I hope you enjoyed this
video if you liked this video give it a
big thumbs up and don't forget to Like
share and subscribe thank you